you watch the undoom you might have  noticed that one of the stars of the  show Nicole Kidman sang the theme song  we did inspired by Nicole stars of your  other favorite shows are now singing  their theme songs on Now That's What I  Call theme song sung by the stars of the  show so enjoy this original theme song  that was cut from the opening of Queen's  gamut and drugs and drugs and chess girl  playing chess then doing drugs then  playing  this script was written in 15 minutes  before show time right it had to be  we'll do it live probably by the janitor  or someone they have a team of writers  right a team of writers  came up with this and they all said it  was good did hackers like hack into the  SNL broadcast and pipe this skit in  to embarrass the show I'm just trying to  figure it out because this is bad